My name is Ahmad Bahye, I'm a data Analyst
course manager at Udacity
and I'd like to talk to you about
one million arab coders' business analyst
program
The aim of the program is to provide students
with
the fundamental skills and expertise for analyzing
data.
Delving into more details, first the program
starts by teaching
students necessary basics of statistics and
programming
Then the program focuses on improving the
students' skills in
collecting and analyzing data and explaining
the analysis results
and how to present the results in a correct
and simple way to take part in decision making
By the end of the program students should
have the sufficient technical knowledge
that qualifies them to start their journey
of
research and self-development to become data
analysts
As for job opportunities, where there is data
there's the
need to extract information needed for decision
making
And this is where the Data Analyst's role
comes in
with job opportunities present at data-centric
corporations like Microsoft and Google
in addition to jobs at companies and institutions
in the fields of support and decision-making
The aim of this program is to provide
oppurtunnities with no prior conditions
in order to educate the highest number of
skilled data anaysts.
this matters because it helps develop each
individual
and his technological knowledge, enabling
them to utilize
the available technology to serve the community
and society